what a excellent point all of a sudden
we have to assume that Facebook knows
everything like they're The Wizard of Oz
get out of here so the Tates came back
with the with the new Rumble stream
today after a week off yeah I have a
little surprise for you in the video
it's pretty cool this isn't my surprise
he the truth about what's happening and
aren't afraid to say it well interesting
fact about them they are currently in
the gym looking good in great shape they
don't look like sexual predators is that
interesting fact isn't that funny the
guys who kind of get it they're in the
gym building themselves up talking to
each other probably spotting each other
watching each other out doesn't mean
they're not instructional predators and
these are the people with something good
to say yeah I mean interesting yeah
quite an interesting point it's a good
point there we have a few other people
who said some good things here we have
based mom have you heard of the based
mother
there's a guy who watches my videos with
his mother and she uh she comments on
them and she's pretty based I haven't
seen all of them I hope maybe she's
sometimes are you kidding me sure fair
enough but that's fine that's fine
surprise this particular clip was it's
these gobones here because she made a
very good point that I love I'm not
kidding you play it to everyone out here
what about their fact Checkers remember
all their Checkers and how we were
supposed to trust them and they were
wrong about [ __ ] almost everything
and here they are again yeah that but
those fact Checkers only work on social
media things when when it's uh when it's
a [ __ ] narrative they're trying to
push on you but when they want Tate to
be called the misogynist they want him
to be taken down and destroyed as a man
they don't they don't fact check those
little those little fake tick tocks and
no videos nope I was sitting outside
working on like my University earlier
and my DMs started getting lit up
they're like the kids are watching you
the Tates are watching you wow guys
that's awesome thanks you didn't look at
the YouTube comments or anything did you
no you told me you had a surprise for me
so I like surprises so I don't I never
peek oh my God I love it let's see what
they gotta say what a [ __ ] excellent
point
excellent these fact Checkers the ones
that purported the lie that you'd be
afraid of the common cold the ones that
got convinced mass amount to people to
lock themselves in their houses the ones
that convinced you to not believe your
own eyes and your own ears about
anything when it comes to elections or
viruses or anything else fact Checkers
who are out here to protect the truth
they are only existing and they're only
around when they're trying to purport
and force a [ __ ] narrative down your
neck as soon as they start lying about
me not a single social media fact
Checker came along and said no this has
been debunked he's not just misogynist
no one no this has been not been
debunked he didn't hit that girl
non-consensually not a single one no
fact Checkers to be found in fact quite
the opposite crickets Cricket all the
videos that are made in support of me
were deleted in real time and the
algorithm artificially pumped all the
videos that were talking complete
[ __ ] misinformed garbage about me
yeah and he's not the first one that the
fact Checkers didn't fact check on look
at all the [ __ ] that they [ __ ] on
the right with because it's convenient
for their narrative they don't fact
check any of that either it's been
proven that the government goes to these
social media companies and they
literally tell them what's the truth and
what they can and can't show it happened
with the Zuckerberg thing it happened
with covid where Biden made this big
speech that anybody who says anything
against a vaccine that's misinformation
and we gotta censor it next week they
have this this freaking truth stuff yeah
vaccinate your kids kids are having
heart attacks good job no but the thing
is that they don't even let you just
like discuss about the other side you
can't even argue about is there enough
data for 18 to 30 year olds about the
vaccine is it worth it for these people
like you can't even have that
conversation without these companies
shutting you down right because the
government goes to them and tells tells
them that we need our engine under push
and and everyone just said the fact
Checker said this the fact Checker said
that that's wrong instead of the actual
reality that science is meant to be
discussed it's meant to be questions
it's meant to if if science wasn't meant
to be questioned we would still be in
the Dark Ages people would never be
questioning is this right is this wrong
how can we make it better how can we
disprove or we confirm something but
they just have an agenda that they want
to push and it's very convenient that a
lot of these politicians had a financial
stake in selling That vaccine and I'm
not saying the vaccine is bad because
the vaccine did a really good job for
people who were really um older people
and people with real vulnerability fat
people it did help it did help to
protect people from going you know too
far in covid so I'm not an anti-vaxxer
but I am anti having [ __ ] shoved down
your throat and I am anti-fact checking
when the facts aren't even first of all
the facts aren't even in and second of
all who are these fact Checkers anyway
nerd sitting in Facebook basement what
is that how do they know everything all
of a sudden we have to assume that
Facebook knows everything like they're
The Wizard of Oz get out of here you
know how hard it is to even find
statistics about the vaccine online it's
like impossible I think we're making
Grandma mad guys look out for my mother
putting nasty comments on her Facebook
video oh it's coming so all these fact
Checkers although it was already known
they're nothing but tools of the Matrix
and tools of the system to just silence
other people now what a [ __ ] amazing
point they never exist to save anybody
from anything they only exist to make a
good excuse for why the social media
companies could delete [ __ ] they don't
want you to see because it doesn't put
the narrative they are trying to make
you do you know how much they lied to us
about covid initially I'm glad you
brought this up and I appreciate the the
shout out but this is very uh it is very
important for people to realize
initially initially with covet it was
the two weeks to flatten the curve and
then when the vaccine stuff was starting
to come along it was get the vaccine
you'll be immune to covid you're saving
lives and then they divided people so
they were like anybody who doesn't want
to get the vaccine they want your
grandparents to die and they're
basically pro-death and then two months
later it turns into oh actually you can
still spread covid and then what do they
say they're like oh if you get the
vaccine you don't go to wear a mask
anymore then they came back with wear
double masks they wait not only did they
come back with double Mass they said oh
you're not vaccinated still oh yeah I
know now your kid can't go to school oh
you can't go to a ball game you can't go
to a restaurant you can't do anything if
you don't get the shot that they tell
you to get even though the shot doesn't
really work and they said that the
vaccine actually doesn't prevent you
from getting covered it diminishes
symptoms and that you need to um wear a
mask again and then two weeks later you
needed to wear two masks like the whole
science flipped so many times and just
last month the CDC came out and was like
uh basically I'm paraphrasing but the
CDC the head of the CDC came out and
said um you know what kind of salary we
botched everything all of it was wrong
but you know we're gonna do better in
the future like how about you all get
fired and hire some real brains to run
the operation but they won't even they
were wrong no they did you missed it yes
they came out the head of the CDC and
was like oh well sorry I'm sorry guys
sorry we shut down businesses and ruined
economies and destroyed lives and people
had to die alone in the hospital and
someone and children are going to be
years behind in Social and educational
skills because oops you know what's
hilarious too is that they'll give the
10K student loan that relief to people
who willingly got into that debt and the
the people who the government told that
they couldn't open their business what
did they get did they get anything they
did get some government relief grants
and loans and yes they did get help but
apparently it wasn't enough help because
I've met so many absolute amount of
businesses closed down permanently like
Boston after this whole coveted stuff
they come out and they're like oh if you
want outdoor seating you have to pay
four thousand dollars a month these
people are horrible because we had
coveted shutdowns they were able to have
some outdoor seating then we had uh then
they had the vaccine mandates which
really hurt their businesses although a
hell of a lot of people I know had uh
vaccine cards yeah everybody got a guy
everybody had a guy it really was insane
though they're like you get the vaccine
you don't need to wear a mask two weeks
later you have to get you have to wear a
mask again and then the day like the day
they said oh actually wearing two masks
is better you're out walking the dog and
all these people are there with their
double masks on and you're like will you
believe anything these people say
they're legit droids I've seen people
riding their bicycle alone with the mask
with a mask you see like the Coast Guard
and stuff would they would arrest people
for like surfing alone you couldn't even
go to the beach during covid they shut
down that that's right people got
arrested for surfing alone
like come on come on like this is why we
we have come to not trust their their
judgment and then these same people that
make all the laws there's proof of them
going out and it's breaking everything
Nancy getting a haircut out of here get
lost woman looks great for her age she
has kids who are obviously 21 22 years
of age she hasn't got green hair you
know she carries herself well her son's
in shape you can literally look at these
people when people say this guy made a
video about you and they show me the
screen for the first one second I know
if it's good or bad I immediately know
if it's a hit piece or some [ __ ]
video or I know if it's a good video
just from what they look like we have a
video here of the news supporting me
thank You Tristan in Australia or the
news in England sticking up for me yes
Australia these are two women who are
who are sticking up for me pretty cool
though that was your surprise that's a
great surprise that's a great surprise
thanks guys really I'm glad because
we're we're on the same page on a lot of
on a lot of things and I'm glad that
resonated with them and shout out to the
Tates I just joined the war room right
after that I saw I saw they said good
messages only for guys is it only for
guys well the well the uh mainly for
guys the all the like the uh marketing
around it says for men well yeah I mean
that's it's like becoming a strong man
you know that's like kind of what it's
about going through I know I want to go
with it though I'm in it I don't know if
you're able to I had to try and I'll
just use Sunny's login sorry guys and
until you make a cat fight room yeah I
had to sign an NDA so I don't know how
much I can disclose even though you're
my mother I'm sorry you got to pay me
we'll just slice your cut of the YouTube
money I won't go in the war room
that's fine I don't mind that it's just
for men like I I don't mind that at all
I just know that that knowledge is also
useful for women especially women who
are raising men like women need that
knowledge if they don't have it already
in order to raise good men so that they
don't have so that they start off on the
right foot and they don't end up with
blue hair crying in the corner well over
to be saved from [ __ ] head nonsense
overall that's pretty cool though that
the Tates have watched some of our
videos It's pretty dope truly appreciate
it I'm excited for my journey in the war
room I am too let's see where we're
going I know I have to take a trip to
Transylvania all right guys we're coming
to Romania we're going to want to go to
Transylvania mom see the vampires she's
not coming so make sure to join the
Discord in my bio uh follow us on Rumble
YouTube has been taking down some of our
videos so definitely uh Branch out my
mom's Sunny mother Sunny's mother on
Instagram Sonny fast on all socials for
me familiar later
[Music]